san francisco berceau par excellence des
entreprises du web parmi fierté de la
ville
trois compagnies entre est de
révolutionner le transport urbain ou
beurs leaf et side-car grâce à leurs
applications mobiles des conducteurs et
passagers se retrouvent et font leur
route ensemble
quand tony mort et habite le sunset des
strictes dans le sud ouest de la ville
et il n'a pas de voiture
ce midi il utilise left pour aller
travailler au centre ville à sept km de
là sur son téléphone une carte gps lui
ai dit qu en temps réel où sont les
membres de lift qui ont une voiture et
qui sont les plus proches
là ça peut me montrer combien de minutes
ça va prend pour quelqu'un qui pourra me
me cherchais l'attend n'est jamais
longue tellement l'application et
populaire à san francisco plage eiffel a
request qu'il ya quelqu'un qui a accepté
de venir me chercher ils vont venir dans
moins de dix minutes
ça me donne le style de voiture qu'elle
quelques couleurs donc ça me donne le
nom du chauffeur et ça me dit que sur
les 5 étoiles
il a un 4,9 donc il est quelqu'un qui a
ses bientôt